Det är ett bolag som bara, det går så jävla bra för oss, så det här och det här händer och det här och det här händer.
Men sen vet man inte hur mycket av det är fake, hur mycket av det är att de går igenom en jättestor kris.
Då ska man också som bolag jämföra inte med andra, för du vet inte vad som har hänt bakom kristna.
Men är det så, nu gick vi in, du ska få berätta lite om dig själv, men jag bara hoppar in här lite.
Nu kanske jag får skit för detta, men jag säger...
Jag håller med.
Men, vad brinner ni mest för?
Idag välkomnar vi Per Scheng och Per Dika från Baibano till podden Make Sweden Strong.
Välkommen!
Tack, då kul att vara här!
Detta är första gången jag gör en inspelning med ett dubbelgäng, eller ni sitter båda två, så det är...
Vi skulle inte ha något försnack, men vi har suttit och pratat i tio minuter.
Det känns som att ni...
Det här kommer att bli svårt att rådda, känner jag.
Hur är läget?
Det är bra, det är onsdag, det är...
Man vet inte vad det är för datum, men vi kör på.
Men det är också en bra vecka.
Det känns som att det är mycket beroende på dagsformen.
Det här är en bra...
Nu mår man bra liksom.
Förra veckan, natt som match.
Nej men upp och ner hela tiden, exakt.
Jag fick önskemål att vara med er i podden.
Det var några som skrev att det hände mycket hos er.
Och nu precis innan jag klickade in här på inspelningen så kom det upp en annons, inte från er utan från Trade, där de hade er som sin poster-girl får man väl säga då, där det stod att ni har ökat till typ 10 miljoner i omsättning.
Tack vare Trade, det kanske inte är bara tack vare Trade, men liksom stämmer det?
Det är en jävla tillväxt i så fall.
Ja men det stämmer att vi har ökat väldigt mycket, så 2025 för oss var verkligen vår breakthrough year.
Och vi har ju guppat lite innan och kämpat på.
Och man vill inte skylla på att ekonomin har varit dålig, utan man vill ju ändå såhär, okej men vad är det vi har gjort då, vad är det vi kan göra annorlunda.
Så vi hade ju lite så känslomässigt, en bottom i mitten på 2024.
Att vi var såhär, men om inte det här lyfter inom ett år, då är vi för dåliga på att driva bolag, då kanske inte vi ska göra det här.
Men vi sätter det som en deadline, att om det inte har lyft till mitten på 2025, då kanske vi ska hitta andra deltidsjobb.
För då är inte vi rätt personer, eller inte rätt bra, eller någonting måste inte stämma.
För det måste lyfta egentligen.
Exakt, för vi lanserade 2021, men det var först 2023 som jag gick på heltid, och Syrien gick på heltid 2024.
Så vi kände ändå att vi räknade tiden från då.
Sen vet ni själva att det kan ta lång tid för bolag att lyfta.
Men det är inte heller kul när man ligger på så låg nivå hela tiden.
Så då satt det verkligen och sa vad vi kan göra.
Man dyker upp jobbet varje dag och försöker lite bättre.
Men det känns inte där och då som att någonting händer.
Men sen blir det som en ketchup-effekt, för att allt du har gjort som har förbättrats blir akumulerat.
Sen såg vi effekten under 2025.
Då var det främst fokus på att förbättra produkt och förbättra marknadsföring.
Det var det som gjorde att det låsnade till slut.
Så det är superkul.
Exakt, jag tänker att vi ska gå in i det där, men bara så att folk är med på det.
Ni säljer väskor.
Exakt, som en mischat mot jobbväskor.
Så business-väskor, off-the-bag, helt enkelt snygga väskor som har alla de funktionella perks som du alltid vill ha i en jobbväska.
Och du är och Inor då?
Exakt, vi började med det här för att jag jobbade som människa konsulterare.
Det är en väldigt mansam lilla bransch, alla mina mänliga kollegor hade portföljer, såg väldigt proffsigt ut och jag hade ingen motsvarighet.
Då frågade jag mina kringliga kollegor, vad har ni för jobbväskor när jag började?
Alla var, det finns inga, det är skitsvårt att hitta.
Portföljen var lite för ful kanske för oss kvinnor och man ville inte heller gå till Elgand och köpa en sån praktisk ful väska.
Sen fanns det många totebags som var som en stort svart hål, men det är väldigt smala band, inga fack.
Så vi såg verkligen ett behov och det var också många i vår nät som tyckte samma behov.
Därför är vi ett väldigt nischat bolag som vill vara kända för att göra den perfekta jobbväskan, som inte kompromissar på varken stil eller funktion, utan hos oss får det båda två.
Och för mig som liksom inte, jag är ju ryggsex-människar liksom, bara så ni kan känna förraktet här från er sida mot min sida då, men, eller ICA-kasse, men jag var inne på er sida och det var ju liksom en ny värld där.
Det fanns 12 timmars väska och det fanns 24 timmars väska.
Vad är det för någonting?
Det har jag aldrig hört talas om.
Ja, när jag var konsult så åkte jag utomlands ganska mycket på en klientuppdrag.
Och det sista året så åkte jag mycket på att man bara övnat en natt, så man åker med en väldigt liten packning.
Och då kände jag att när man flög att kabinväskan var alldeles för stor för bara en natt, medan den vanliga väskan var för liten för man ville ha med sig om en liten ombyte till dagen efter och så där.
Så då var det ju så här, men gud jag saknar verkligen en väska som ser proffsigt ut, som är snygg men som passar just för de här kortare resorna.
Just en eller två nätter.
Och då skapade vi 24 timmars väskan.
Så jag vet inte om du har sett alla funktioner, men den går ju att fälla ut som en resväska och den har massa små fack.
För när jag reser, eller när jag reser jobbet, så tycker jag inte om att plocka upp allting jag hade i väskan men bara skulle stanna en natt.
Det är skillnad på det att stanna en hel vecka, då orkar man ju göra det på tällrummet.
Så att man verkligen snabbt kan hitta allting och så.
Efter det så började jag använda den väskan till gymmet och fick feedback från kunderna.
Då kände vi att den väskan var lite för stor om man till exempel ska gå och träna.
För när man tränar med sin massa grejer, skor och kläder kanske bland andra.
Då har vi sagt att vi kanske ska ta fram en 12 timmars väska som är perfekt för dagar då du ska gå och träna och gå till jobbet och ha det allting var organiserat, separerat i olika fack så att din dator inte blir blöt.
Det började med, först kommer vi på jobbväskan som du har på dagen och sen 24 timmars väskan och sen 12 timmars väskan.
Det är olika behov så varje väska har sitt syfte.
Vem är det som har designat allting?
Är det ni som designar?
Ja exakt, det är jag som är huvuddesignen men vi är ett väldigt litet team så jag tar hjälp av Syran och av teamet liksom här.
Men jag har ju haft ett väldigt stort designintresse sen jag var liten men ändå valt en akademisk banan och det kommer jag också in på sen.
Så det har alltid varit jättekul med design men sen kunde jag inte ha några designverktyg så vi designar faktiskt än idag fortfarande allting i powerpoint för det som kom såg ut i lärarni på powerpoint excel.
Och det funkar ganska bra för då visar min powerpoint-sketch till fabriken och de har ju då ett riktigt program som de översätter det till så att det går att få ut en riktning.
Är jag lite baibano, är det ditt sätt att få att designa för ni har ju en fuckload med designer här, absolut ni har omsatt ni lite mer men under några år har ni omsatt ett par miljoner och ändå är det fan hur många olika väskor har ni.
Det är ganska vanligt att man kanske lanserar två väskor men ni måste ha 50 väskor här.
Ja SKU är relativt många men just väskmodellerna då snackar vi runt åtta stycken så det är inte jättemånga väskor i sig utan det är många färger de finns i.
Det är ju för att man behöver ha bredden till businesskvinnan.
Jag tycker tvärtom för det var så roligt.
Vi fick ju se lite av frågorna innan vi började här och det var en av dina frågor exakt denna då.
Och då tänkte vi bara, vad har vi så mycket produkter?
För oss har det känts som att vi har varit väldigt nischade mot just jobbväskan.
Vi håller inte på att göra kläder, väskor och accessoarer utan vi är bara på datorväskan i princip och dess accessoarer.
Så det handlar ju om att helt enkelt kunna catera en och samma kund som kanske en dag i veckan.
Siklar behöver hon en ryggsäck några dagar, är hon inne på viktiga möten, då har hon en briefcase.
När hon jobbar i resan behöver hon en 24-hour.
Så blir det helt enkelt att man bara caterar hela livsstilen.
Men än idag tycker väl inte vi att vi har så många produkter.
Nej, jag skulle säga att när vi lanserade 2021 lanserade vi bara med en modell, och det är Singerturealcase.
Det står idag för 50 procent av omsättningen, men innan stod den för mycket mer.
Så nu när vi har lanserat fler väskor så ser vi också hur de tar lite av marknadsandelarna.
Vilket är jättekul för vår insikt är också att du kommer inte hitta en väskmodell som alla kvinnor kommer vilja ha, utan du måste ha några olika.
Och jag tror inte vi hade kommit upp i 10-11 miljoners omsättning på bara en väskmodell.
Och sen då år två släppte vi två till, och sen har vi varje år släppt en till två modeller.
Så det känns för oss, om man jämför med ett modevarumärke, som att det går väldigt långsamt.
För ett klassiskt färsumel släpper ju hur mycket som helst, både höst och vår, medan vi har släppt en ny modell, kanske per år, och sen några nya färger.
Och sen försöker vi också ta bort färger som inte säljer längre och så vidare.
Ja jag är inne här, för mig ser det ut som 200 väskor, men det är väl för att jag tycker att allt ser, nej jag förstår, jag fattar inte riktigt målgruppen.
Men är det inte krångligt att hålla på och binda, det är ganska dyra väskor, eller jag tycker det i alla fall, men liksom är det inte krångligt att hålla på och binda detta i lager?
Hur har ni löst?
Varför tar ni fram en massa olika färger?
Funkar inte detta precis som med t-shirtar, folk köper svart.
Behöver man de andra färgerna?
Men det är det som är så intressant att hade du bara haft svart på hemsidan så hade du inte sålt svart lika bra, så du måste ha de andra färgerna för att kunna sälja svart.
Just förra året så var faktiskt brunt en av våra mest populära färger.
Många köpte svart, men många köpte brunt, burgundy.
Det är också samma där, att det är den balansen mellan vad det är som faktiskt säljer och vad man måste visa för att få intresse för att köpa svart.
Och vad är det som folk faktiskt vill ha andra färger för att de har återkommit under kunder som vill köpa samma väska en annan färg.
Men när det kommer till lagerbindning, vi har snarare haft problem att vi under 2025 sålde slut väldigt mycket.
Så verkligen missbedömde kapaciteten och missbedömde efterfrågan under 2025.
Vi tänkte att vi skulle dubbla omsättningen men det blev ju mer.
Och då fick vi istället sälja väldigt mycket på pre-order.
Så då blev det att det blev väldigt trevligt för kassaflödet men såklart inte jättekul för kunder som fick vänta ibland upp till tre månader på sin väska som de hade föransköpt.
Vi hade vissa dagar, 11 days, en inventory.
Alltså vi snurrar lagret, jag vet inte, 20 gånger.
Alltså det var jättemycket att vi snurrade lagret.
Så vi har inte haft det problemet.
Och så hela vår supply-channel i Europa.
Så det kan ju liksom inte massivt öka vår produktionskapacitet utan det kommer att ske långsamt liksom.
För vi är ett slow fashion brand, ett ena dej.
Så, ja.
Binda lagen har inte varit två grejer.
Också lite fördel med att vara i mitt premium är ju att kunderna väljer att vänta.
Du kanske inte orkar vänta för att man saknar att betala hundra spänn på.
Men om det är liksom en investering som den har gått att tänka på ganska mycket så kommer ändå inte göra så mycket för din kommenteringsförmåga.
Har det nästan varit en grej att man ska vänta lite grann?
Har ni kunnat bygga på det, höja priser och liksom nästan göra en väntelista av det och göra en ja, om du har köpt de här tre, då får du köpa den här.
Det är jättespännande, vi har tänkt på det en massa gånger.
Och helt ärligt så har vi bara inte hunnit med.
2025 var otroligt hektiskt och fin tillväxt absolut, men det kräver också extremt mycket arbete bakom.
Men det vi gjorde var bara att vi sålde på Prodeo, det är helt enkelt, och hade den processen.
Men absolut att det skapade en FOMO, det gör det ju självklart.
Men jag vet själv när jag kollar och ska shoppa och ser att en viss färg är slut, det kanske inte är den jag vill ha.
Men då blir jag såhär, oj den måste vara poppis.
Så vi märkte faktiskt att nu är det inte så länge, men när vi inte hade svart guld i lager så sålde den jättemycket och var verkligen topp.
Men när den fanns i lager så sålde Mokka bättre, som var slut såld.
Så det blir också lite, jag tror att man vill ha det man inte kan få.
Sen har det ju vissa, jag gör det här strategiskt, att de väljer att köpa in mini lager eller bara helt enkelt inte ärliga med att det faktiskt inte är slut sålt.
För oss har det verkligen varit en brist på kapacitet och jag tror absolut att vi hade kunnat nå 15 eller mer om vi hade lager, för vi stod ju där i december, typ 10-12.
Och vi kunde inte leverera fler till julhandeln helt enkelt.
Så det är någonting vi jobbar väldigt hårt med det här året, men också ett extremt stort arbete såklart, att hitta bra craftsmän, women och mens som verkligen kan göra med väskorna och göra den kvaliteten som vi vill stå för.
25 kan sammanfattas med att så fort vi fick en produkt när vi lager så hade de redan sålt.
Så då blev det såklart.
Vi hade typ två i över.
Det var så.
Men jätte...
Häll du idén att inte faktum att man inte kan sälja sina produkter, men det är klarare att bygga ut eller växa ett bolag om du inte har helt hundra procent koll på din supply chain och den kapaciteten som krävs för att växa.
Så det är ingen långsiktig strategi, utan det bara blev så.
Kan ni känna en viss rädsla nu inför 2026?
Lägger ni ordrar i förväg till fabriker eller köper ni material åt fabrikerna i förväg?
Jag bara tänker att när man har haft en såpass snabb tillväxt på ett år så måste det vara ganska svårt att prognostisera hur 2026 ska bli.
För det kan ju bli precis vad som helst.
Vi har tre olika budgetar som vi jobbar med.
Vi har en budget som vi gärna vill nå, budget A.
Den är att vi ska fortsätta i samma takt.
Det är det vi planerar för, i bästa fall kan vi få in det här lagret 2026.
Vi märker redan nu också även för 2027, vår kapacitet måste jobba för att öka kapaciteten.
Just som Per-Dika sa, vi jobbar med mindre fabriker.
De kan inte öka i samma tempo som vi gör, för då kommer de tappa sin kvalitet.
Då handlar det om att vi behöver hitta en ny fabrik att komplettera med.
Idag börjar vi med tre fabriker till exempel, men när vi startar behöver man jobba med en.
Det är så man får jobba lite.
Men att man hela tiden...
Hos oss är det jag som sköter inköp och det är nåt jag faktiskt inte tycker är jättekul, men det blir att man får tvinga sig själva att nu måste vi sätta prognosen för hela året och verkligen prata med leverantörerna och så här kommer det se ut, det här behöver vi köpa in och sen börja sätta de här inköpen.
Men egentligen hade man velat att det skulle vara lite mer på kortare sikt för att det är mindre risk så att säga, men det är så man får göra helt enkelt för att ändå säkra att man får in produkterna som man behöver.
Sen är det en fördel att vi kör ingen seasonärlighet på våra produkter, det är inte säsongsläpp som man behöver göra, vi kör aldrig med några det whatsoever förutom en fem procent i skan förstövande online, annars hittar du inga det hos oss.
Så det gör ju också att vi inte har det här behovet utan råkar överköpa in på en viss produkt så kommer vi kunna sälja den nästa höst.
Så det är inte att man behöver få bort det sortimentet eller har hyllvärme om man inte ska ha det här.
Så det är väl också förlängd för nu är det femte året vi kör och då har vi ganska mycket data på oss.
Vi vet att de här modellerna säljer väldigt bra.
Så vi köper in många av dem.
Nu har vi också vågat köpa in väldigt många.
Vi vet att de kommer sälja i värsta fall lite långsammare ifall vi har för många lager.
Men sen när vi släpper någonting nytt då är vi lite riska värsta och tar in ganska få för att testa.
För vi tycker fortfarande att den bästa kundundersökningen det är när folk faktiskt börjar köpa och se.
Man kan alltid fråga in förväg men det är bättre om de faktiskt om de köper ser hur köps den här jämfört med de andra.
Och då går det bra kan man köpa in mer och så kanske det ändrar lite vilka produkter som säljer.
Vad är det som har fått att folk väljer att vänta några månader på de här produkterna?
Jag följer ju inte som sagt den här världen så jag liksom inte säger.
Är det 30 ultratrendiga människor som går runt och berättar varje dag?
Eller syns de på något visst ställe?
Eller vad är det någon marknadsföringsgrej?
Eller är det varumärket eller är det att det finns inget sådant här?
Vad är det som är så jävla speciellt?
Jag menar det på det mest kärleksfulla sättet liksom.
Ja, absolut.
Nej men två grejer skulle jag säga.
Den första är definitivt produkten.
Alltså vi startades ju ur ett genuint behov av att den här produkten fanns inte.
Jag tycker att väskan överlag är väldigt utdaterad, den är som ett svart hål.
Alltså det finns inga fickor whatsoever, den har typ inte utvecklats på hundratals år.
Den ser likadant ut som den alltid har gjort, sen kanske den ser externt och annorlunda ut, men intern så är den lika tråkig och modern.
Så vi erbjuder ju liksom jättemycket fack och förvaring där kvinnor i dag kanske till och med behöver köpa en fin väska och sedan behöver de köpa en organiserade till väskan.
Så det blir två köp för att grundprodukten gör inte jobbet.
Så vi har ju massa funktioner, vi har liksom en rem som brukar fästa på resväskan.
Den är väldigt stilig, väldigt fin.
Så när du reser, inte behöver klångla med att väskan är nere.
Det är skitjobbigt och jag själv tycker synd om alla känner sig på flygplatsen och det på behända i.
Den har liksom ett datorfack så att den slipper vändas ut.
Du vet själv, en massa trycker ner dator i väskan.
Det ser bara oproffsigt ut.
Den har massa småfack med dragkedjor för värdesaker.
Den är bara sjukt smart och den är väl genomtänkt.
Den har bredare band så du inte ska få ont i axeln.
Men den är verkligen så engineered som vi brukar säga för businesskvinnan.
I den sektorn är vi väldigt ensamma med den här typen av produkt faktiskt.
Det finns ett fåtal varumärken men vi snackar under fem stycken som gör det här.
Den ena saken är absolut produkt och att den är snygg och samtidigt funktionell.
Den andra saken tror jag handlar om att i barnen har det blivit mer än bara produkten och det känns som att alla säger det här om sitt inne varumärket, det är mer än en produkt.
Men generellt för oss så är det ett sätt för oss att visa på att jämfälldheten är på rätt väg.
Våra kunder har sagt till oss att de ser en barnväska på stan, tänker om vad jobbar hon med, men det är direkt förknippande med businesskvinnor och det är liksom en symbol för kvinnors klatt i samhället om man säger så.
Så det har också blivit att man tar det är ett ställningstagandet när du köper en väska.
Det är inte bara en produkt och du får alla funktioner, utan du blir också, man fattar direkt att du är en businesskvinna.
För att som du själv vet, ser man en man på stan med en portfölj och kostym, då tänker man, ja någon jätteklok man som tar några beslut som är viktiga i något så stort kontor, och är säkert på någon bra position.
För kvinnor har det inte funnits, utan samma väskor bärs av samma typ av branschfolk i princip.
Då blir det inte att man har den här symbolen på att här kommer en kvinna som tar viktiga beslut, och också i jämställdhetsfrågan så måste man ha förebildat sig upp till.
Vi har inte kunnat offentliggöra dem på samma sätt, för att ofta är ju businesskvinnor inte så himla amående om att synas på sociala medier kanske.
Och då för unga tjejer att kunna se kvinnor på stan gå runt med väskan så kommer de fram på ett annat sätt.
Så det har också varit en annan del att vi har tryckt på att bygga brandet och varumärket runt den här atmosfären kring businesskvinnan.
Och hur rent krasst menar du att ni har gjort det?
Är det att er marknadsföring är byggd på det sättet?
Eller att ni samarbetar med, ni använder inte modeller utan ni använder affärskvinnor?
Eller vad är liksom, för jag förstår vad du menar men hur bygger man den feelingen?
Ja men det är ett nytt långsiktigt byggande skulle jag säga.
Vi har varit, om jag får säga själv, duktiga på att sprida vår gospel som är hela vår brandstory.
Vi är liksom kvinnorna vi själva tycker är byvana kvinnor.
Jag är läkare, pyschenge, ingenjör.
Vi båda hade kunnat vara kunder till varumärket.
Och vi har hela tiden försökt förklara vårt problemlösnings, alltså när produkter löser ett problem men också varför vi valde att göra det här.
Så det är i princip att man står med skylt och då är den här väskannen för businesskvinnor en power woman, alltså varje dag i kundens fyl.
Men på olika sätt att bara sprida gosspens.
Vi har inte varit fega med att våga säga samma sak tusen gånger.
Det är någonting vi varit duktiga på.
Jag skulle säga att vi har haft en otroligt begränsad budget och du vet ju själv att om man inte har pengar tillverkar man så måste man lägga ner tid.
Så att vi har lagt, i och med att produkten kommer utifrån ett problem så har vi verkligen fokuserat på produkten i marknadsföringen och berättat alla funktioner och varför vi tog fram den.
Sen har vi som står bakom produkten som berättas av att vi också är potentiella kunder till varumärket så då känns det generint att om det här är något som jag själv hade haft på mig eller något som vi själv har ett behov av.
Då kan ju folk utifrån när vi själva syns väldigt mycket i marknadsföringen och syns fortfarande mycket i marknadsföringen, att man ändå ser i alla fall två personer här som kanske har mycket medsatt med våra kunder.
Sedan får ju det spillover effekt på folk som går på stan och allting.
Men vi hade jättegärna velat göra något större av det och samarbeta med vissneskvinnor, folk som har marknadsföring, inte bara modeller som du säger.
Men det är något som varit ganska resurskravande tid och pengar, men det är något vi absolut vill utforska längre.
Det finns ju också många som branschvidear eller styrelsekvinnor, de såg direkt att den här kunden var skapat för dem, så de blev väldigt organiskt kunder till oss.
Och då blir det att de frontar oss på alla kontor och så vidare.
Så då blir det ju ändå en känsla av att rätt kund har hittats till produkten och kan i sin tur liksom word of mouth sprida gossipen.
Vi får ju höra väldigt mycket att någon bara men gud vad är det där för väska?
Som Pegas sa att det är ett snack som går på kontoret.
Och eftersom det har varit ett problem att den här väskan inte finns, och oftast då är våra kunder i en manstrommel bransch, många är jurister, de är, om jag var inne på finans, konsultning och så vidare, då blir det ju att alla de här tjejerna, då flockas fingren här, men gud vad är det där för någonting?
Och så vill de, och det är ju den bästa rekommendationen ju, att man köper någonting som ens kollega eller kompis har köpt.
Och om de kan voucha sig att det här produkten är jättebra, då leder ju det till ett köp för dem också, vilket är jättekul.
Om vi går tillbaks till det vi började med, att 2025 blev någon sorts ultraår när ni tog fart, eller vad vi ska kalla det.
Det var ju inte så att folk rekommenderade väskan 2024.
Vad var det som hände 2025 som bara, fan, nu funkade allting.
Kan ni se några så här specifika grejer, eller var det bara att, det var inte så att ekonomin bara totalt vände det året.
Vad var det som hände 2025?
Finns det några avgörande punkter som gjorde att det tog fart?
Alltså ett väldigt tråkigt svar är att det är massa små förbättringar som har kumulerats.
Men en sak som absolut har bidragit är att vi fick en större islä på NK, syntes direkt när det kom in i varor, att ha de som backar varumärket och en idé, vi har supergod kontakt med dem och relation med NK, och de är supporters av ByBono och vi älskar NK.
Så det är en väldigt bra subiös mellan våra varumärken, och vi har varit en av deras bäst bestärande varumärken sen vi började sälja där länge.
Det tror jag är en grej att folk verkligen bör vänja sig.
Får jag fråga hur mycket säljs via NK och hur mycket säljs via egen e-handel?
För är det er enda butik som ni ställer er till?
Ja men exakt.
Vi har lite olika butiker kan man säga.
Vi körs en spitta mellan wholesale och det är 90% e-handel, lite se och 10% wholesale.
Och då har vi också Nordstroms i USA.
Inte butiker utan hemsidan och även sådant.
Bloomingdale, det vågar jag ändå säga nu.
Och lite små butiks i Sverige.
Två stycken bara.
Bybinet, Bodengatan och även Ysterborg och Oles Döttrar.
Vi vill väldigt gärna hålla det intint och lite luxury, så det finns överallt.
Så det är en ny vettensstrategi.
Det är absolut en sak.
Sen får man också respekt för att det är ganska långa konverteringscyklar för den här typen av produkt.
Så det är ingenting man kollar på ena dagar och andra dagen konverterar.
Så är det väldigt mycket i Saudi vill jag säga, men inte i Sverige.
Jag kan ändå berätta en sak som verkligen fick rulla.
Det var att vi hade byggt upp en contentmaskin, man kanske inte fått meta i rullning på det sättet.
Det var lätt att vi behövde någon som trodde på vårt content, och kunde satsa på det.
Så då tog vi in Amanda McKee som du har haft i podden.
Hon är helt otrolig och är exakt det alla säger att hon är.
Ja vad skönt att hon inte bara snackar skit.
Pred till Amanda.
Hon är verkligen helt otrolig och hennes grafer stämmer vill jag säga för det hände exakt med oss.
Hon gav fem timmar i veckan och varje gång vi ses är det så här du gjorde det här för oss och hon säger nej nej nej ni gjorde det och jag hjälpte ju bara lite så.
Så vi är lite så i.
Jag tycker att båda två har varit helt otroliga vid det här samarbetet.
Det var bara en klockligen match i det stadiet.
Vilket då gjorde att vi satte igång vår maskin helt enkelt.
Och Meta var det som drev mycket av försäljningen.
Sen vill jag också bara lägga till på SupplyChain-sidan.
När vi lanserade ByBano så var produkten inte så bra.
Det var inte för att vi nerevettigt lanserade en dålig produkt.
Det var för att vi var inte västexperter.
Vi var västentusiaster och vi hade en helt annan bakgrund.
Så vi tyckte att vi hittade en fabrik och trodde att den var bra.
Den låg i Estland och försökte få ut den på marknadsport som möjligt.
Tyckte att den var bra.
Sen märkte man efter ett tag att den håller inte mot det.
Jag tror absolut inte att vi hade varit över idag om vi inte hade förbättrat produkten.
Så vi har hela tiden, så mycket vi kan, förbättrat, förbättrat, förbättrat.
Sen kom vi till en punkt under 2023 där vi var såhär, vi måste byta fabrik.
För den här fabriken kan inte bättre kvalitet.
För vi var såhär, är det vi som är dumma i huvudet eller är det de som inte har kompetens ännu?
Då gav vi oss ut på en resa, besökte tio fabriker i Spanien och Portugal och gjorde en jätteomvändning.
Det skulle jag säga också var väldigt avgörande för att vi skulle komma upp i den volymen.
För då är också kvaliteten en helt annan.
Samma med det kunde vi öka priserna, för vi kunde inte ha de här priserna idag för den gamla kvaliteten.
För det skulle inte alls funka.
Så allting har ju hängt ihop och som Perika sa, det tar ju tid att konvertera en kund.
Vissa personer behöver se väskan på stan för att kunna vara överkrigad.
För det är ett väldigt stort köp.
Det är en väldigt hög average order value och jag har stor respekt för det.
Det är jättehäftigt att kunderna har det förtroendet för oss som nytt varumärke och lägger så mycket pengar.
Hur har ni lyckats sätta den, kallar man det lyxstämpel, men är det inte lite läskigt att bara, här är en väska, den kostar sju papp nu, köp den tack.
Vi har ingen bakgrund i någon väskeproduktion, men man betalar åtta gånger mer än den här andra grejen.
Jag vet inte vad en väska kostar.
Men liksom, vad är det som avgör att en väska är lyxig och hur har ni fått den stämpen?
Det är ju jättebra fråga och första svaret är väl att absolut.
Det är lite läskigt, det är det självklart.
Hur får man lyxstämpen egentligen?
Jag tror att det handlar mycket om att vara, vi kläder oss med de varumärkena som tycker att företaget ska förknippas med.
Fick ni byta Garderover när ni startade bolaget?
Vi har alltid varit de personerna, det har nog varit sen jag varit student, det kanske inte alltid har gått, men absolut kvalitet och kvantitet har det alltid varit för oss båda.
Så det är absolut en sak.
Men också att förstå att lyxvarmäken måste också, det kommer också med några hygienfaktorer såklart.
Det måste vara en viss typ av content, en viss typ av crisp, editorial, alltså modeller och så vidare.
Och att man faktiskt vågar investera i det.
Så att våga investera i rätt saker skulle jag säga, för vissa saker är inte lika viktiga.
Och vissa saker är hygienfaktorer, till exempel att hemsidan ser bra ut, att kundkörelsen är top notch, att produkten i sig faktiskt ger det värdet den lovar att den ger.
Och vi jobbar ju liksom i samma fabriker som stora lyxvaruhus.
Så det är ju den typen av kvalitet, men de tar ju ett pris som är kanske 30-40 000.
Vi tar ju 7 000.
Och då plötsligt tycker vi att vi ger värde till kunden.
Så då vågar vi liksom stå på och säga att det här är jättebra och du får faktiskt välja upp mycket för priset och vi använder samma typ av material som den här lyxförelsen.
Så jag tror bara i produkt så är den redan i lyxfaktoren och då är det enkelt att göra en lyxprodukt.
Vi brukar bara kolla vilka material som är lyxiga, använder de och göra en bra väska.
Men sen också i varumärket handlar det ju mer om att inte tumma på svågrejer som är väldigt viktiga, till exempel att inte ta egna bilder och lägga ut i handen, utan att våga investera, ta in en bra fotograf, ta in modeller, men såklart göra det till en kostnad som är rimlig och inte smälla på en halv miljon bara för att det kan bli så bra, utan hitta en nivå så att hygienen ändå uppnås, men inte kanske maxas.
Men jag skulle säga att om man tänker traditionellt på ett premiumvärdigt varumärke och det låter som att okej, du måste lägga flera hundratusen på photoshoes, du måste ha jättekul editorialkampanjer, du måste ha jättekul samarbeten.
Och det var ju uterslutet för oss, vi hade inte alls den budgeten.
Så det som är skönt då när man är ett startup och inte kan, man riskar inte lika mycket för du har inte byggt värsta läggelsen som du kan, som kan fallera.
Då är det ju såhär okej, no-shave, ställ oss framför kameran, vi pratar, vi filmar.
Och det som är coolt som jag insett är att man kan bygga premiumcontent trots att det är jag syran framför kameran.
Det är bara att ha en bra iPhone, bra kvalitet, ha bra ljud, en mick kostar tusen spänn kanske.
Och sen, va välklädd och visa upp, bäst kan visa kvaliteten i närbild, visa alla funktioner.
Någonting som våra kunder i jättemånga år alltid har brytt sig om det är kvalitet.
Vår kund vill hellre ha denna kurerade garderoben än att köpa massa skit.
Och att betala 7000 för någonting som är tillverkligt i Europa det är bra kvalitet, det kommer att hålla i väldigt många år.
Plötsligt blir det väldigt prisvärt.
Och i samtidigt som det här så har ju alla lyxvarumärken megahöjt sina priser under covid.
Så jag minns bara för några år sedan, om man skulle köpa en väska från Balenciaga eller Prada, då kostade den ut 15000 och 15000 är såklart jättemycket pengar för många människor.
Men nu kostar samma väska 30-40 000.
Och då blir gapet mellan då en premieprodukt som vår och en lyxprodukt mycket mycket större.
Och då hamnar inte kunden i den här diskussionen ska jag ha en Louis Vuitton eller en Baibane för det är så stor skillnad i pris.
Vilka är det ni slåss mot eller vilka blir era konkurrenter i nuläget?
Vad är alternativet för kunderna?
Vi har ju de typiska toten, alltså stora väskor utan fack, öppna väskor om man säger så.
Så det är absolut, jag skulle säga att kunderna kommer från två håll.
Det ena hållet kommer de från mer funktionella, inte lika stiliga.
Det kanske är en jättebra ryggsäck som inte har massa fack, men den är inte snygg helt enkelt.
Eller så är det den här snygga Louis Tom toten som är helt öppen.
Den ser bra ut men shit vad den är jobbig att använda för den har smala band, skär in i den axel, allting ligger huller och buller.
När du ska dra upp sladden på mötet så ser det ut som ett råttbo.
Vi kommer från de två hållens.
Indirekta konkurrenter är de två.
Våra direkta konkurrenter som gör exakt samma sak som oss, det har vi ut i två, tre varumärken bara.
Vi skulle säga också bryr sig om kvalitet och lyx.
När vi började fanns det ingenting, då var vi själva på marknaden och det är också därför vi startade.
Sen har det med tiden kommit tre varumärken, men där har det lite varit en divide.
Det finns de som tillverkar i Kina, säljer för kanske runt 2000 kronor.
Samma funktion, absolut lite stilig, men de kan ju inte heller investera i varumärket, de vill inte bygga ett brand.
De är mycket med D2C, Ecom, bryr sig bara om snabba konverteringar.
De försöker inte ens lägga sig i mitt premium, och jag tycker inte att det är vår kund.
Vi är absolut att några kan gå dit, men då är inte Rundberg Barnmark kund om det inte blir med kvalitet.
Och sen så åt det andra hållet, där det faktiskt finns folk som bryr sig om både premiumsegmentet, är Europa producerar direkt direkt konkurrenter.
Det är egentligen bara annorlunda design på våra väskor.
Där finns det kanske två stycken.
Så vi är ändå ganska ensamma om det.
Ni kör på ganska många marknader eller?
Jag gissar att Sverige inte är den enda marknaden.
Nej men precis.
Så det är också så här, när man lanserar ett varumärke så är det klart man tänker direkt på ja vi ska vara globala men sen kan man inte helt plötsligt spendera pengar överallt.
Utan man börjar i Sverige som man brukar göra.
Men för oss har det blivit globalt ganska organiskt just för att vi har varit så himla tunga på sociala medier, särskilt TikTok.
Och när vi var, eller vi är fortfarande jätteaktiva på TikTok, men vi började också in i tid och det var mycket lättare att växa där.
Och när en video blir viral och får fler miljoner visningar, då är det inte fler miljoner svenskar som ser den här, utan det är över hela världen.
Och vad vi såg var att det var väldigt mycket spidning ut till USA, sen blev det väldigt spidning ut till Saudi-Arabien och spidning ut till Asien.
Så all vår försäljning fram till december 2024, som var utomlands, var helt organiskt.
Vi blådde inte en enda krona på det.
Så det vi la på betalmarknadsföringet var Meta och inom Sverige.
Det var egentligen när vi började jobba med Amanda.
Hon var såhär, vad händer ifall vi lägger pengar på de här marknaderna som ni redan har mycket försäljning till?
Så tills dess var ju våra största marknader också såhär USA, Saudi, UAE.
Och jag tror att Sverige då stod för kanske 30 procent av omsättningen under 2024.
Nu minns jag inte exakt i mitt huvud, men det var inte majoriteten.
Och i år, under 2025, vågade vi spendera pengar på de all andra marknader, såg hur de växte.
Idag består fortfarande då Saudi, UAE, USA och Sverige står för kanske 70 procent av omsättningen.
Svenska andelen har sjunkit för att de andra marknaderna har vuxit snabbare.
Och sen är vi väldigt förstående kring att okej men Sverige, i och med att vi ändå har PMI-produkter, har en väldigt typisk kund.
Vår kund har ju mer gemensamt kanske med någon som bor i New York eller Paris än andra i Sverige.
Vi fattar att vi inte kommer att byta miljöbolag i Sverige på våra produkter, utan vi behöver växa utomlands.
För att svara på din fråga, vi har väldigt global försäljning och fokuset för 2026 är att fokusera på marknadsmedelsinsatser på de största marknaderna.
Och växa med i Mellanöstern, USA och sen fortsatt i Sverige för att vi ändå har byggt lite mer varumärket kännedom här, vi har NK.
Så här kan vi se att konverterings, eller vad ska man säga, kacken är lägre för att folk känner till det på ett annat sätt.
Men sen är svenskar, man är mer kostnadsmedveten, vi märker att A och V är mycket lägre i Sverige.
Jag tänkte fråga, har ni olika priser ut mot kund i olika länder?
För det känns som att premiumsegmentet är en grej här och den är en grej i ett annat land.
Så det är lite spännande där.
Ja ni gör så.
Absolut.
Vi har runt 30% högre i andra marknader.
Och det är också en ganska vanlig strategi.
Vilken är den dyraste marknaden?
Det är Inosa och det kostar i en väska runt 8000.
Vår bästsäljare kostar kanske 6 000 här.
Det ligger runt 8,5.
Och då kan man ju få, vi brukar sälja i bundles och det är skitbra på hemsidan.
Så då kan man köpa väskan, en cable pocket med en kabelorganiserare och även en korthållare eller någonting i en bundle.
Och de går ju alltid på att köpa i bundles och då är det average order value på typ 11.
I stället för 6 och någonting i Sverige.
Finns det något syfte att fortsätta sälja?
Varför plöjer man inte ner allting i den marknaden?
Ja, jag tror ändå att det är viktigt att vi har så bra varumärkeskennadom här i Sverige.
Jag förstår vad du menar, men jag tror att vi ska kunna verkligen, vi vill ju ändå ta över den marknaden lite.
Och jag tror att vi är ganska, inte nära på Sverige, men vi har det enklare att göra här.
Så först bara pre-vars house här och sen också rent fashionmässigt.
Sverige är ett av epicentren kring mode, skandinavisk mode är super inne och jättehett.
Så om Sverige som är så priskänslig, så stilkänslig, kan godkänna vår produkt och säga att den här är skitsbra, då är det ett absolut vinnande koncept att det här går att göra i andra marknader.
Jag såg den här lilla annonsen här strax innan, då var det ju trade, och trade är ett sånt bolag som bekostar leverantörsfakturer när man köper in lager.
Men ni har ju, som ni sa, ni har ju sjukt snabb omsättningshastighet av lagret.
Varför behöver ni jobba med leverantörsfakturer, eller kreditar på det sättet, vad är det som är problemet där?
Ja men exakt, det handlar egentligen om att, jag skulle ändå säga att för att vi är entreprenörer, så är vi inte super risktagande.
Vi är lite mer åt det riskaversa hållet.
Och absolut, vi har en summa pengar på kontot nu, som känns jättebra och vi tog in en investering under 2025.
Men jag känner då, jag som är CFO i bolaget idag, att jag vill inte lägga varenda krona vi har på att köpa ett jättegötter lager.
För tänk om någonting händer och det gör att någonting i verksamheten går dåligt, försäljningen sjunker och sen behöver vi kunna lösa rätt fasta kostnader i löner och så där.
Så det känns väldigt tryggt att fortsätta använda trade, men sen använder vi den kortare betalningstiden.
Så vi maxar inte för att självklart det kostar ju ränta att använda trade.
Så det är inte mer ur ett riskperspektiv att göra det.
Det känns bättre för verksamheten just nu, men det är klart när vi växer kassan mer och mer, då kan vi mer och mer använda våra egna pengar för att göra dem inköpen.
Jag gillar hur vi har totalt motsatt, jag brukar köpa lager så fort vi har en spänn på kassan.
Jag tror vi ligger tomma 9 av 10 månader.
Men absolut.
Du, med omsätt gemesur, jag vill kaska lyssna på dig.
Ja men vi har noll spänn i vinst så det jämnar ut sig där någonstans.
Jag fattar, okej okej.
Och 2026 här, kan ni inte ta mig lite...
Jag är väldigt intresserad av hur man spinner vidare på.
Rent procentuellt, vad omsatt ni för förra året?
Tre miljoner eller sånt där?
Nej.
Menar du 24?
Ja.
Ja det minns jag inte hur.
3,9 och 3,7 år mer exakt i siffrorna.
Okej men säga att ni har liksom vuxit med 250-300 procent nu.
Ja.
Kan ni se att ni håller i tillväxttakten?
Fortsätter ni växa eller känner ni att ni stagnerar av här en stund och liksom hittar balansen?
Hur tänker man rent psykologiskt kring det här?
Hur vi tänker psykologiskt är genom att vara strukturerad.
Så vi har satt tre olika budgetar.
Så A, B och C som har olika omsättningsscenarion.
Det vi ser som vår största tillväxtdriver är ju fortsatt vår e-handel.
Så det är där vi tror att om vi ska tripla igen så är det via e-handel.
Det är inte att vi helt plötsligt har signat upp en massa wholesalekonton, för det är någonting som en helt annan business tar jättemycket tid och inget som är lika lätt att förutse oss vidare.
Så vi har tre budgetar.
Då har vi satt också så mycket vi behöver omsätta månadsvis för att nå budget A till exempel.
Och just nu taktar vi på bra på den budgeten.
Så i tanken att vi varje kvartal gör en utvärdering, har vi nått budgeten på budget A.
Om det är mycket lägre då kanske vi i stället ska fortsätta på budget B och så vidare.
Jag köper det här att ni har tre olika budgetar, men när ni har pratat med era leverantörer och när ni sätter spänden i marknadsföring, har ni gjort beställningar för det bra scenarioet eller mittens scenarioet och så får ni trycka på, absolut ni har tre budgetar, vilken är det ni satsar på?
Exakt, så vi satsar på budget A när det kommer till omsättning och rörliga kostnader.
Med rörliga kostnader menar vi inköp av lager, performance marketing och logistik såklart.
Men vi satsar på budget B som är sämre när det kommer till fasta kostnader.
För det värsta, jag är jättedödd för fasta kostnader, man vill inte ha för mycket av det i sitt företag, man vill snabbt kunna skala ner på saker ifall någonting inte skulle gå bra.
Men sen har vi en väldigt ärlig dialog med fabriken, så när vi lägger beställningar, så vi har lagt order för hela året, men vi har också sagt att skulle vi se att försäljningen drastiskt minskar, så kommer vi se till, i alla fall tre månader i förväg, och säga att vi kanske behöver dra ner lite på.
Så vi har en väldigt bra relation med dem och inte så här att vi 100% måste kommitta till den här volymen vi har satt, utan mer okej, vi har kommittat det första halvåret och sen får vi berätta för dem att nej men det går inte som vi tänkt, vi hade behövt dra ner, hur ser ni på det?
Och de är helt med på det, så det gäller ju bara att ha den här öppna dialogen och växa tillsammans.
För det här är en fabrik som, en av våra största fabriker är ju supertajta med oss och vill växa med oss.
För de vill också bli en större leverantör och växa sin business och vi är väldigt viktiga för dem för att de ska kunna göra det.
Sen är det också en fördel att vi producerar inte i Asien, man behöver inte ligga jättestora MOQ'er, utan vi får veckoväsa leveranser.
Så då kan man dra i handbromsen att okej nu tar vi två månader framåt men sen måste vi nog minska lite.
Så att det inte är att man får in tusentals väskor som man sitter på.
Utan vi kan köra långsamt och följa försäljningstakten.
Vi utför hela tiden och kollar hur länge vi sitter på lagret, olika modeller och sen har vi inte definierat heller exakt alla väskmodeller vi ska ha i höst till exempel, utan vi har sagt att vi kommer att behöva ungefär såhär många väskor.
När det närmar sig att de behöver beställa material, då definierar vi de här färgerna.
Så vi försöker ändå vara lite kort in på, och bestämma sådana saker i nära dialog med dem.
Den här investeraren, vad var det för Nissa eller Nissa?
Och varför ville de jojna?
Och varför ville ni ha in dem?
Exakt, vi kan ta det från början.
Vi lanserade i slags 2021, och tanken från början var Stronger är jättebra och Ideal is Sweden, och ingen av de bolagen, vad jag vet, hade tagit in kapital och de bara sköt upp i den.
Man tittar alltid på de här 1%-bolagen som gör de här resorna, och då tänker vi lite ur ett ego-perspektiv, gud vi ska också växa helt utan kapital, vi ska göra själva för vi behöver och så vidare.
Men sen hamnar man i verkligheten och måste titta på vad man har för egna förutsättningar.
Vi hade inte så mycket egna pengar att stoppa in, vi hade redan stoppat in allting i bolaget, runt 100 000 liksom, och tagit ett lån från Almi.
Sen var jag också så, jag var 30 år gammal och Perseng var 20 år till sex.
Så vi hade inte åldern att kunna spara och ha värsta kapitalet i ryggen.
Nej men i alla fall, då tänkte vi naivt så här, nej men vi ska växa det här organiskt med våra egna pengar.
Men sen blir det ju det här som du säger, man måste binda kapital och sen är projekten ganska dyr.
Så vi hamnar i ett moment 22.
Plus att jag då jobbade kvar på mitt gamla jobb som konsult och pärgade pluggar fortfarande, så vi lade inte heller heltid på det för att vi hade inte rådet att gå på heltid för vi behöver titta på våra löner och våra hyra och allting.
Så då tänker vi naivt, ja men jag gör det här tills vi är lönsamma och sen kan man säga upp sig, men det orkar man inte.
Jag hör ju på att bli utvänd av det.
Och då fick man tänka om och sätta ett nytt perspektiv, okej men vad är bäst för bolaget?
Jo det är faktiskt i det här att ta ut kapital, för det sämsta som kan hända är att vi både blir utvända och att vi inte har pengar att köpa in lager ungefär.
Så då gick vi ut på en liten kapitalrunda 2022, på hösten, och tog in fyra änglar, så vi tog in en investering på, ja men de tillsammans med allmän, tog in på 2 miljoner ungefär.
Och det gjorde att, då sa vi till investerarna, att en del av de här pengarna kommer att gå till att jag först säger upp mig så att jag kan ta ut en liten lön att leva på, och sen ska resten gå till lager och marknadsföring och sånt, och sen ska Per-Erika plugga klart, och då ska du gå på heltid 24.
Och sen kör vi på den planen, och sen var det ju väldigt tufft såklart att driva bolaget.
Produkten i sig var lönsam, men det måste ju komma upp i en lite högre volym.
Vi kunde inte täcka våra kostnader på 2 timmar i omsättning.
Så vi hade kommit upp i alla fall 6-7 för att vara lönsamma.
Och då fick vi igen så här, okej men vi behöver nog en till push här, innan vi tror att vi kan sustain med vårt ena kapital.
Och det här var under 2024 när det gick väldigt dåligt enligt oss.
Men sen såg vi att vi skulle gå ut på en till kapitalrunda och satt det som deadline då, sommar 2025.
Och sen började ju businessen vända liksom.
För då från december 2024 och framåt började vi ändå komma upp väldigt mycket i omsättning, vi började tripla och så vidare.
Så att vi fick positiv kassaflöde för att vi sålde på pre-order.
Men då var vi ändå såhär, nu är vi investerade i loger, låt oss ändå ta in pengar för man vet aldrig och så vidare.
Och det var ju ganska trög marknad i början.
Men sen du vet, så fort en säger ja, då vill andra haka på.
Och där var vi också lite så, men vi ska bara ta in så mycket som vi behöver, vi vill inte ge bort för mycket av våra andelar.
Men då landar valet till slut på Hagströmmersfamiljen, Avanza grundaren och så.
Så de har en fond som heter BioVestor, som är ett familjeoffice kan man säga.
Så de joinade 2025 tillsammans med att vi fick påfyllt från våra fyra änglar som är helt fantastiska.
Så vi har ett tajt team, våra investerare som vi jobbar tajt med.
Ja, verkligen.
Och vi har så god dialog med dem vilket känns jätteskönt.
Och rolig grej, angående av Avanza eller Hagströmmersfamiljen, är att de var väldigt tidiga investerare i Akne, och har liksom följt den resan och har lite koll på det.
Så det kändes skönt att ha någon i ryggen som också har varit i lycksektorn.
Och hela den biten.
Vad var det folk köpte in på?
Det måste vara lite halvläsget som investerare går in i någonting som ändå är inom mode eller trendigt eller som ska prissättas på ett visst sätt.
Det är ju inte världens säkraste business liksom.
Det är inte mjölkproduktion.
Vad är det folk gillar med er, ni får skryta det är lugnt.
Jag tror att vi två personer som man märker brinner på det vi gör.
Genuin reampension, vi vill göra jobbet, vi sliter verkligen som djur och jag tror att de kunde se det.
Att vi människorna bakom bolaget vill göra det de kan för att det här ska gå helt enkelt.
När vi började rätta upp, precis som Preng sa, i investerardialogen så var vi i ett lite sämre läge där vi knappt hade någon tillväxt från året innan, jättetråkigt.
Men sen när vi började gå in i dialogerna med Hagströmer, då var vi uppe på en 4x det här året när vi träffade dem.
Så vi var i ett läge där vår värdering plötsligt hade blivit väldigt rindlig.
Det var lönsamma, det är kvinnligt grundat bolag.
Vi är två extremt passionerade entreprenörer bakom en väldigt bra produkt som redan finns på en väldigt fina lyxförehus som vi själva har gjort.
Vi har inte fått någon hjälp med det.
De gillar också lyxsektorn, de kommer också lite från den och älskar speciellt vdn på By Vestor som är framgrafis, älskar väskor.
Lyxsegmentet inom väskor.
Det var bara en väldigt bra match där de själva trodde på produkten.
Vi hade inte bara idén utan siffrorna som kunde stötta visionen på något sätt.
Vi hade lite flyt i att så fort som Ferge sa, när vi gick in med dialogerna så såg bara kurvan bättre och bättre ut.
Då hade vi ändå någon sustans bakom det vi sa.
Sen tror jag också att i ett tidigt skede det är riskfyllt att investera i oss jämfört med en aktie på börsen.
Det är att man i främsta rummet investerar i entreprenörerna.
En av våra investerare sa också att ni hade kunnat sälja vad som helst, det hade gått jättebra ändå.
Det var mer att de trodde på oss.
Sen trodde de att oavsett om den här idén inte fungerade skulle vi hitta på något annat som fungerade.
En skön sak att ha i ryggmärgen för oss är att en av våra konkurrenter som började ganska samtidigt som oss har på 5-6 år kommit upp på 150 miljoner omsättning.
Det är till och med dyrare än vad det var.
Det kanske var en tuselat mer.
Så vi vet att det går.
Bara att få se att den här produkten, det finns en efterfrågan, det går ifall man lägger tid och energi.
Sen har de varit på heltid sen start och tror absolut att det är en faktor kring varför de har väcklat snabbare.
Så vi vet i alla fall om att vi kan visa ett case i alla fall.
Vi visar att det inte bara är vi som tror på det här, utan det finns också bevis på att det går att skala till det här bolaget ganska snabbt ändå.
Jag är alltid fascinerad över att man lyckas få in investerare i ett tidigt skede.
För de gör ju en satsning, de vet ju inte.
Som sista grej där skulle jag bara vilja snacka lite om, ni har varit med i ganska mycket, kallar man det för tidningar eller liknande, och ni marknadsför det också mycket på hemsidan.
Den här väskan kan du se här och den här kan du se här och liknande.
Hur jobbar ni med det?
Det är ju rätt många människor som vill synas på rätt platser.
Har ni en direkt kanal rakt in i första uppslaget eller hur ser man till att ens produkter syns?
Nej men helt ärligt har det varit en extremt dyr, lättsa och liksom väg in om man ska vara ärlig.
PR branschen tar alldeles för mycket betalt för alldeles för lite jobb.
Det kan man kort sagt säga och jag tror alla i modebranschen kan skriva under på det för att de kanske är PR-människan själva.
Så det har varit, nej men jag tror väldigt få saker i modevärlden för att valga är så organiska, utan det mesta är ju lite köpt.
Så att vi har ju inte köpt oss till artiklarna, utan köpt en PR-konsult som har varit väldigt, väldigt dyr, som har skapat de här möjligheterna.
Kanske inte hade lagt den satsningen i efterhand, det var väldigt dyrt och det gav kanske inte så mycket som man önskar och det är också därför vi använder det så mycket, för att vi får lite valuta för pengarna.
Men jag tror också, nej men det bidrar ju med validering och så vidare.
Sen kanske den mängden och den skalan, vi är inte nödvändiga.
Det tror inte jag nu i efterhand, men man lär sig alltid.
Så det är en av våra dyrare lexor och sen är det väl fint, men jag tror inte, vi måste ens fråga våra kunder för att vi inte har gjort det, men det är i alla fall ingen som har kommit till oss och sagt att vi köpte i väskor för att ni syntes i våg.
Det har inte varit den.
Men jag vill bara säga att för att vi inte haft pengar innan så har vi varit såhär, men vi kan inte göra sådana grejer, vi måste göra allt själva.
Sen gick Q1 25 jättebra, vi gjorde mycket mer vinsten än vad vi trodde och då var det såhär, men låt oss ta en risk, vi lägger den här vinsten på den här PR-personen.
Då hade vi ändå, det var en person som ett annat varumärkare jobbat med som fått bra resultat, så vi ändå söker.
Vi hade fått lite validering att det här funkar.
Får ett kontrakt där det står såhär, det här är leverablerna som ska ske, det här är vad det kostar.
Allting kändes bara jättetryggt men sen i verkligheten, sanningen är ju att det här inte är en superprofessionell bransch, det finns jättemånga som inte gör sitt jobb.
Sen finns det säkert folk som är superduktiga också, och det är tråkigt för de duktiga människorna, för man blir lite så.
Då blev det att det inte levererades i den magnituden som det var lovat, och samtidigt när man är ett litet varumärkare, man kan ju inte gå på med jurister och försöka, även om vi har ett kontrakt och det har blivit ett kontraktsprott, så har vi inte råd att driva det vidare.
Jag skulle säga att vi fick lite artiklar, men hade vi vetat att det var så få mot vad vi har betalat, då skulle vi kanske inte gjort det alls.
Jag tycker bara att det är ett problem generellt sett i den branschen, att när det går inte att mäta, och det känns som att vi bara häller pengar i sjön, och så är det ju att de här P-kontorna sitter på väldigt fina adresser, och dricker sina matchalatter.
Det är inte den vibe man är så här med världen ni gör.
Varför tar det så lång tid att få i stad?
Jag blir lite skeptisk faktiskt, och det kanske är för att vi har jobbat med fel människor, men vi vet väldigt många som har liknande erfarenheter, så jag tror att det är ett större branschproblem.
Men skulle ett ungt varumärke komma och fråga så är det värt att vara med på er, då skulle vi faktiskt säga nej, lägg de pengarna och tiden på andra saker, bara få upp volymen ännu mer.
Det kanske är jättevärt för ett jättestort bolag som har pengar och som inte behöver se return på det på ett-två år, men samtidigt är det så här, ja, fast är det värt det?
Eller jag vet inte.
Men det är ganska lykt hur Olofsson skulle säga.
Jag tycker att man ett tag sa att det är där vi är just nu, vi ska bara fokusera på att göra en så helvete bra produkt som möjligt och marknadsföra den bra.
Och förhoppningsvis så kommer de till dig.
För det är den absoluta bästa stämpan att en PR-person har åst till dig och skriver hej och gör en artikel, eller att som Blummingdales exempel, de har rast till oss och frågat om vi vill sälja oss dem.
Och det finns inget bättre kvitto än att de kommer till dig istället för att du behöver jaga dem.
Jag bara älskar det, jag tycker vi kan ha det som vanande exempel till typ alla som lyssnar som driver varumärken, för det är likadant i våran bransch såklart.
Vi har också gjort otaliga sådana tester med artiklar i rättgivningar eller olika tester som ska göra sådant här eller utställningar på olika samarbeten, galor, allt möjligt och ingenting ger någonting.
Det är klart att någon människa någon gång säger ja vad coolt att ni var med där, absolut men vi har betalt för det där och vi är inte ens i...
Och räknar man, ska man räkna krast på hur mycket man måste sälja för att få tillbaka den investeringen?
Om man räknar i vad man gör i vinst på en produkt så är det inte ens...
För någonstans lurar man sig själv och tänker ja men jag sålde 10 väskor och vi lade 80 000 på just det där.
Ja det är ju inte sant, man behöver ju få tillbaka vinsten av vad man...
Man behöver sälja betydligt mycket mer än så.
Det är typ aldrig värt, och av alla de här jävla PR-filmerna som vi har jobbat med i några åren, fucking hell vad det är mycket skitsnack och som du säger, man har ett avtal och de gör typ avtalet men det liksom betyder ingenting.
Så att nej, håll er undan från all PR som man måste betala för ett tag.
Ja, jag har sagt att vi lärde oss ändå med allt det här som var en bra lärdom, och den borde kanske inte ha kostat så mycket att få men vi tar den som en positiv grej ur det här.
Det vi måste jobba med är att folk vill lita på.
Det går inte att vi hela tiden, för det är också en sak ekonomisk förlust, en annan sak är tidsmässig emotionell förlust.
I så här, gud vad jobbigt det är att jobba med någon som inte gör som den säger, men det är skittuft.
Vi två professionella, vi gör det vi säger, om du beställer en pluffa så skickar vi den.
Den ska hålla kvalitet, om du inte gör det så hjälper vi dig att ta hand om det.
Då förstår inte jag hur man kan vara i en bransch där man bara lovar saker och inte levererar.
Det blir så jobbigt, det är emotionellt.
Det har vi tagit med oss, att vi mycket hellre jobbar med någon som kanske är 20% inte lika effektiv, men som vi kan lita på att göra sitt jobb och som håller sitt ord.
Där har jag varit väldigt bortskämd i min förra bransch, alltså i mashup-branschen.
Alla mina kollegor är superduktiga, jättemensamma, de gör som de säger.
Man bara kan ni göra det här till imorgon?
Absolut, och så är det gjort.
Så kommer man till den här branschen och folk ljuger hejvilt och gör inte som de säger, det är jätteuppreventionellt.
Sen finns absolut de här stjärnorna som är så jäkla duktiga, men det är så mycket skit också.
Det är lite jobbigt men det är också vad det är, man får helt enkelt bara fokusera på sin egna resa, köta på ändå.
Man har ju alltid bolag som bara, det går så jävla bra för oss, det här och det här händer, och det här och det här händer.
Men sen vet man inte hur mycket av det är fake, hur mycket av det är att de går igenom en jättestor kris.
Då ska man också som bolag eller som ett tips till om det är yngre entreprenörer, jämföra inte med andra för du vet inte vad som har hänt bakom kulisserna, eller vad det har kostat att få ut den här artikeln.
Så man ska bara göra sin grej och ja, väldigt tråkigt att PR-branschen har de utmaningar de har.
Men ja, jag är glad att vi testade.
Man måste våga testa grejer, men man måste också våga säga stopp och bara nej, det här funkar inte.
Nu tar vi den här förlusten, den blev åtminstone lite större än vad den kunde ha blivit.
Det är också en lärde om jag tror att vi tar med oss att failfast, går det inte av för det snabbt, så man inte står där och också de här människorna är otroliga säljare.
Shit vad de kan sälja in saker.
Så de bara nej men det här är på gång, vi lovar.
Och så bara hände absolut ingenting, så då var det tre månader senare med samma utgifter.
Men bara vara ärliga på mitten.
Vi kan bara hålla på där för evigt.
Det har varit en dyr läxa 20-25 och en absolut, jag tror vår största huvudvärk.
Trots det var vi lönsamma, så det är ändå kul.
De här människorna som snackar, för det är en vanlig grej också hur man ska bemöta.
Branschen är ju liten, oavsett vilken bransch man är så springer man på samma människor om och om igen.
Hur brukar ni bemöta dem?
Om ni vet att en person underlevererar eller snackar lite skit, brukar ni ta den konflikten och tar du med dem eller brukar ni bara feda ut och försvinna?
Jag tror förr i tiden så vågade vi inte ta konflikten.
Vi tänkte att word of mouth om oss kommer att vara dåligt, vi kommer inte att den kanske säger något till någon annan som förstör en bro där.
Medan jag tror att nu när vi ändå är några år in, jag tror att vi har ett rykte om att vi är trovärdiga med individer.
Så vi är inte rädda längre på det sättet att vi tar konflikten, vi är jobbiga, vi är vi.
Och du ska göra som du säger för oavsett om den personen sedan går och berättar för någon annan person att vi har varit dumma mot den och kanske varit lite hårda eller jättejobbiga att ha att göra med.
Men då kan vi alltid kontra med att det här var situationen och faktamässigt har vi rätt i vår sak.
Så jag tror att idag så tar vi konflikten så länge vi kan få någonting tillbaka.
Alltså vi har inget behov av att säga att du är jättedålig ifall vi inte får någonting av det.
Men är det så att du skyller oss pengar så kommer vi att be dig att skicka tillbaka pengarna tills du har gjort det om man säger så.
Så när man lär sig, man har fått lite mer raka i ryggen.
Man vågar stå för vad vi tycker och gör.
Men skulle ett annat enhet skulle ha kommit till oss, vad tyckte ni om den här samarbetspartnerna?
Då kommer vi säga som det är.
Men sen kommer inte vi skriva ett art-inlägg till alla på LinkedIn och bara trasha en person.
Vi vill ju inte råka för förtal och sånt där.
Det är inte heller professionellt och det är inte där vi ska lägga vår energi.
Men sen kommer något till oss och frågar ärligt och kommer vi svara ärligt.
För vi vill inte att den erfarenheten vi hade stressbilar sig till andra.
Och sen tror jag, det är en väldigt tuff bransch, det är väldigt många spelare, men de som gör sitt jobb och igen, det kommer alltid gå bra för de personerna.
Det tror jag.
Det är väl ett bra slutråd att lägga och ni som startar upp inom modervärlden och vill ha PR, ring tjejerna på Baibano och fråga vem man ska samarbeta med och vem man absolut inte ska samarbeta med.
Stort tack för att ni var med i podden och grymt jobbat.
Tack snabbt.
Jag gillar hur vi har totalt motsatt...
Jag brukar köpa lager så fort vi har en spänn på kassan.
Jag tror vi ligger tomma 9 av 10 månader.
Men absolut.